hello and welcome to the 10th php
tutorial
uh where we left off we were doing the
while and for loops i thought i might do
the for each loop but i think we'll hold
off on that until we
kind of discuss arrays real quick that's
really what the four h is is mostly for
it's running through like an array or a
list so with that let's pop into
uh the switch statement
so
with that let's
just define a variable we'll just say
examplevar is the variable
and we'll say examplevar
equals
two
so uh to set up a switch if you haven't
guessed uh it will be switch parameter
and then what to do
as always
and so what we can do with this
is we'll say the parameter
is examplevar
and then down here we specify what to
happen in various cases so the purpose
of switch is almost like if you found
yourself wanting to do
a bunch of if statements so if you were
thinking okay i want if um if example of
r is 1 do this if example bar is 2 do
this if example var is three do this
the best scenario for you would be the
switch statement
so
the next thing you'll do once you'll
once you have it is you'll say case
one
you'll we'll just say uh if it's case
one we're gonna echo
uh
i guess we should just echo case one
then
uh what you'll do
is come over here and you'll just call
for a break
then immediately you'll specify case two
and then we'll go ahead and echo
case two
oh i almost forgot my break
break
case three
echo
case
three
oops inside the space here
and then of course break
and a good thing to do
just like if you had like if if if if
um in a switch state like if you just
had a bunch of ifs it wouldn't be a big
deal if you didn't have anything in the
switch statement it's not really the
hugest deal it just won't spit anything
out
but you can also specify a default so
it'd be like if if if else
but you so the default
same thing will just echo up the default
that makes sense
break and then
we close the switch statement already
so what we'll go ahead and do is save
this and put it up
and we'll refresh parse error i left a
colon out somewhere in our variable
and forgot my break let's try again
we'll get there we'll get there there we
go case two because the variable was
indeed two
um so what happens if we put a string
variable in here in fact what happens if
we turn two
itself into a string
and just so you know that we have
appended or changed this we'll just
add an exclamation mark there
refresh
save i guess i forgot to save it or
something
yes
fresh there it is case two
actually it's case two
anyway
um so yeah you can put it in the string
as well and so it's basically uh doing
if you recall
equals equals not equals equals equals
so by the same token you could say
johnny
is our example bar
we'll save that
pop over here refresh and you can see up
we got the default but we can also throw
johnny into a case of course
in case johnny pops up
we'll echo
there's johnny
and we'll of course escape this quote
come down and we'll of course break as
well
and make this pretty
we'll save that
refresh and sure enough there's
johnny so anyway uh that's pretty much
the switch statement
so um congratulations now you know the
switch statement as always thank you for
watching thanks for your support your
subscriptions and until next time